the first teaser trailer drop for the
Black Widow standalone movie from Marvel
the film takes us back in time and
introduces us to a host of characters we
haven't seen before here's a breakdown
of the characters in the teaser who they
are and what we know about them plus an
explanation of a few other key Easter
eggs
let's briefly start with the main
character Black Widow aka natasha
romanoff while a black widow movie might
initially seem confusing because we saw
the character die in avengers endgame
this movie actually takes place in the
past and appears to explore her somewhat
mysterious backstory in the timeline for
the Marvel Cinematic Universe this movie
is set to take place right after the
events of Captain America Civil War in
that film Black Widow was forced to go
into hiding she became a wanted criminal
when she betrayed Thaddeus Ross and the
US government by helping Captain America
escape from the German Airport with
Bucky Barnes aka the Winter Soldier
Addie aged Thaddeus Ross appears briefly
at the start of the trailer for Black
Widow along with a number of troops
it seems he's trying to hunt down Black
Widow the first person that Black Widow
reunites with in the teaser trailer is
Yelena Bulova played by Florence Pugh
who she calls her sis
Bulova first appeared in the comics and
Inhumans number 5 and there's no record
that she is not real sister it's
possible they use that term of
endearment because when they were
younger they trained together in the Red
Room a place where female spies were
groomed to be Soviet agents it seems
from the trailer that the two have a
messy history which explains this fight
scene and is also backed up by the
comics at a point Bulova was even sent
to kill Natasha in the comics Bulova as
Natasha successor eventually becoming
Black Widow when Black Widow is killed
by hydras Captain America look-alike
Bulova reassumed the Black Widow
identity and fights for the good guys
because the Tasha died in endgame as far
as we know it seems highly likely that
Florence pew as Yelena Bulova will be
our new face for Black Widow that brings
us to this guy red Guardian now in the
comics there were several people who
wore the mantle of red Guardian but
actor David Harbor of stranger things
Fame is listed as Alexei szostak off the
second person to assume the mantle of
the legendary Soviet fighter one thing
that remains to be seen is if Shostak
often Natasha were ever married because
for a period in the comics they were
together it's possible because right
before
were introduced to the character we hear
the line enemy a hell of a reunion and
later in the trailer he says which could
mean that they were an item at one point
in the MCU timeline we know that he's
not Natasha's father because an endgame
we learned her father's name is Ivan
although Ivan is probably a reference to
Ivan Petrovich who in the comics is just
not adopted father who took her to be
trained as a Soviet spy Black Widow and
Red Guardian were both trained as Soviet
agents so it's likely their paths would
have first crossed during that time in
the comics Shostak Hoff was a pilot but
was chosen for an experiment when the
Soviets realized they should have a
rival soldier to Captain America they
went so far as to give him a shield that
magnetically returns to him and looking
at his costume in the teaser trailer you
can see his parallels with cap we also
get a brief glimpse of Molina vasta
cough played by Rachel vice we don't
learn much about her from the teaser
trailer literally all she says is [ __ ]
but she's playing a potentially
important character Iron Maiden
we don't see it in the trailer but that
character is often wearing a skin like
metal exoskeleton which increases her
strength hopefully we'll get to see her
like this in the movie like Bulova she
also was trained in the Red Room but was
always out shown by Natasha which
harbored a hatred between the two
characters lake Bulova vaster cough was
also sent to kill Natasha Iron Maiden as
a character with an interesting history
in the comics having been part of a
group called the femme is on and a
lieutenant for superior a notable Marvel
villain so who's the guy with the bow
and arrow
that's taskmaster a villain who has
photographic reflexes and is able to
instantly replicate the physical
movement of his adversaries gaining
deadly archery abilities from Hawkeye
for example once the taskmaster has
mastered an opponent's physical
movements he can then predict his
opponent's next attack past master first
appeared in The Avengers number 196 his
real name is Tony masters and he was
born with photographic reflexes which
allowed him to effort
replicate the movements of top athletes
after seeing them on television and
during one mission he injected himself
with a syringe containing an
experimental Nazi version of the Super
Soldier serum the serum that turned
Steve Rogers into Captain America the
syringe enhanced his reflexes and
allowed him to instantaneously mimic the
fighting style and movements of his
opponents however a side-effect of the
serum was severe memory loss causing him
to forget that he was ever in shield in
the comics he's capable of holding his
own against Captain America spider-man
and more so it makes sense that he
appears to be fairly evenly matched with
Red Guardian in the trailer although we
are curious as to how taskmaster shield
got buried in the floor at the end of
the trailer it appears that his henchmen
are chasing after Black Widow as the
skydiving soldiers have masks that
resemble taskmasters on top of all the
characters there are also some Easter
eggs in the teaser the opening shot of
the trailer shows Budapest
Black Widow has mentioned Budapest
several times in Marvel movies vaguely
referencing a mission that happened in
the city with Hawkeye several times
throughout the Infinity Saga the first
time it's mentioned is in Avengers
during the Battle of New York
Black Widow quips to Hawkeye the next
time we hear about Budapest is in
Captain America Winter Soldier
when Alexander Pierce warned Romanoff
that all her dark secrets including
Budapest would come out if she exposed
Hydra and shield if you do this none of
your past is gonna remain hidden that
Budapest not Osaka the final time that
we hear about Budapest is during
Avengers endgame
so it appears that something important
happened to black widow while she was in
Budapest with Hawkeye however all of the
previously referenced events happened
before the Black Widow movie occurs in
the MCU timeline maybe we'll learn about
Natasha's history with Budapest in the
movie another reference to the MCU is
the opening line of the trailer Natasha
says nothing this is a line from
Avengers endgame from a conversation she
had with Steve Rogers after five years
had passed since Thanos is first snap
next we get a host of shots from past
Marvel movies here we see knots vision
from Avengers age of Ultron she appears
to remember her ballet training and spy
training back in Russia when Scarlet
Witch gets into her mind next we see a
shot of not walking this is from the
first Avengers movie when she brings
Captain America inside shields airship
for the very first time right after that
we see a shot from later in the same
movie Clinton Natasha exchange looks
after Clint is finally released from
Loki's mind control then after a quick
shot of Nick Fury we see Natasha
shooting while falling through a
corridor this is a shot from an early
scene in Captain America Winter Soldier
where she and Kat board a ship to save
hostages and recover shield intelligence
throughout this video we've referenced
the Red Room a couple times and we even
get a small glimpse of this infamous
location in the teaser but it's not the
first time we've heard of it in the MCU
not mentions it in an intimate scene in
Avengers age of Ultron in the Red Room
where I was trained where I was raised
they have a graduation ceremony they
sterilize you one final Easter egg is
that it appears the vest that Yelena is
wearing in the trailer is the same vest
that we see Natalia wearing an infinity
war this seems like an ominous sign for
Yelena but we'll have to wait until the
movie's release to find out for sure
so there you have it was there anything
we missed
let us know in the comments
[Music]